كما قلنا قال صحيفه احرنوت قبل قليل ان
نتنياهو ابلغ لاداره الامريكيه نيته تجميد
التعديلات القضائيه كان متحدث باسم البيت
الابيض قد قال ان الولايات المتحده تشعر
بقلق بالغ النزاع الاحداث في اسرائيل وتحث
القاده هناك على توصل الى تسويه في اقرب
وقت ممكن
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
قال ان الرئيس بايدن كان قد ناقش مع رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ضروره
بقاء القيم الديمقراطيه سمه مميزه للعلاقه
بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل وذكر
المتحدث ان واشنطن تشعر بقلق عميق
التطورات ومن التاثير المحتمل على
الاستعداد العسكري للجيش الاسرائيلي
الينا من واشنطن مراسله الجزيره بسن ابو
كويك طبعا بسنه اسالك عن كيف تتابع واشنطن
هذه التطورات المتلاحقه في
اسرائيل وكذلك ما نقلتها صحيفه اديعوت
احرنوت بان نتنياهو ابلغ الاداره
الامريكيه نيته تجميد تعديلات القضائيه
وسيله يعني طبعا تتابع ما يحدث في اسرائيل
من تطورات بقلق عميق وذلك طبعا انعكس على
في البيان الذي صدر في وقت متاخر من ليله
امس من قبل المتحدث باسم المجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي طبعا التابع للبيت الابيض
الولايات المتحده خصوصا اداره الرئيس
بايدن التي تضع قضيه الديمقراطيه ربما في
جل سياساتها خصوصا هنا
داخليا عادت لتركز في ذلك البيان
استمرارا لتحذيرات ربما سابقه كانت قد
وجهتها تحذيرات غير مسبوقه
لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
من مغبه المضي قدما بتلك التغييرات
القضائيه وتاثيراتها على الديمقراطيه في
اسرائيل البيان الذي صدر عن بيت الابيض
كان يتحدث على ان قضيه التوازنات والضوابط
هي ربما اساس المجتمعات الدي
وقضيه الديمقراطيه هي
يعني والحفاظ على النظام والقيم
الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل هي ركيزه للعلاقه
الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه لذا واشنطن قلقه تريد من جميع
الاطراف التوصل الى تسويه باسرع وقت ممكن
بيان البيت الابيض يتحدث على ان اي
تغييرات جوهريه في النظام الديمقراطي
يتطلب اوسع قدر من التاييد الشعبي طبعا
هناك تاكيد على ان الولايات المتحده ما
زالت ملتزمه بامن اسرائيل ولكن ايضا
بديمقراطيتها وربما هذه الجمله التي اختتم
فيها ذلك البيان بالنسبه لقضيه ابلاغ
الولايات المتحده
بالعزوف حتى هذه اللحظه عن المضي قدما
بتلك التغييرات حتى الان ليس لدينا اي
تاكيد طبعا واضح رغم هذه محادثات كانت
مغلقه ما بين الطرفين فلا يوجد تعليق بعض
من البيت الابيض على هذا التطور الذي
نقلته يدعود احرنوت ولكن ايضا وسيله ننوه
الى ان هناك قلق حتى في اوساط الكونجرس
ليس فقط في البيت الابيض ايذاء ما يحدث في
اسرائيل وهذا القلق ربما انعكس في تصريحات
على مدار الاسابيع الماضيه خوف بين اوساط
اصوات ديمقراطيه بارزه من المضي قدما بتلك
التغييرات القضائيه وتاثير ذلك على
الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل كما يقولون حتى
اللحظه لم تصدر تصريحات واضحه من اعضاء
الكونجرس ولكن كان هناك ربما
تغريده لافته من عضو في لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخه سنه الديمقراطي
براين تشات الذي قال انه يتابع ما يحدث
باسرائيل بقلق بخوف وهو امر مروع كما وصفه
ويهدد ما يحدث الوضع في اسرائيل وانه
يتضامن مع المتظاهرين الخارجين
للدفاع عن الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل على حد
وصفه شكرا جزيلا لك بسببك مراسله من
واشنطن